daniel faivre voit la jeune retraitée 66
ans groupe grand père aussi père de
trois enfants en métropole grand père de
cinq petits enfants
on est fiers que les faits qu'elle y
travaille bien il n'y a pas de problèmes
liés d'un p des raisons que l'impé
difficultés et sont âgées les handicapés
j'ai créé l'association en 2008 à sig
association solidarité inter génération
aa alors pour but c'est plutôt
administratif c'est d'aider les
personnes c'est d'apporter un savoir aux
personnes sur les lenteurs
administratives les dysfonctionnements
administratifs
je ne me sens pas comme quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire mais comme lanceur
d'alert la priorité la dollée la phrase
qui tiennent de mon association c'est
solidarité qu'il faut retenir la
solidarité intergénérations 6e la
solidarité se remet sur la réunion là il
y aurait beaucoup moins de problèmes
sociaux